I was a fan of yours since I was quite
young since I was like 13
however as I started to learn the Deen I
came across some stuff you said which
was completely contradicting Islam you
can't just be studying at home and
giving dower like this this is not the
way to go
you do look at this and this is the
reason why how young kids like this get
brainwashed by Isis they killed 3,000
people but these are the things you
don't see in the news because of
deceptive chefs like yourself look how
disgusting mu cheese and we're I'm
trying to speak for all these idiots who
actually follow you but mature for now
with my clothes had holes in them I'm
afro is picky - the night east maschino
and Versace my snow laces in the raw
cheese new millennium I said I'm worried
come to my better care to brothers and
sisters and difference why am I wearing
this because my haircut went a bit wrong
my wife cut it that's another video for
the four hundred thousand subscriber
celebration which is going to come out
this weekend shout out with my wife cuts
my hair so I was just about to go sleep
I was appealing I stood before them
start the caustic then I came across
this video it was a life on most immense
Instagram where he invited a sister who
was continuously saying rude stuff about
him so he for the machine right and
talked to her we're going to be reacted
that no for the whole thing the whole
things about 17 18 minutes I've down to
10 minutes the juicy parts well it will
react into that now but first I wanna
present most of our notes are the most
merciful the most just or praise His
glory and gratitude belong to him for
the work that we do in sha Allah you
like what I'm wearing check out the link
to one of our sponsors each other so I
wanna make some very clear I don't want
people to think that I defend multi man
or chef like them or anybody else for
the sake of it yeah just because you
know I'm benefiting from them you know
his famous and one life was my witness
is Ramadan be like
if I am defending these individuals eh
ah - may Allah bless em p.m. of the men
be it my worst enemy whoever it may be
if I am defending them because they have
some kind of benefit towards me may
Allah protect me from that I pray for my
intentions if mostly men or Shahi thermo
myself ever maybe if I see them doing
wrong in public and calling people to
the fire I don't care how many
subscribers they have I don't care
just because I've been so I'm doing this
video yeah so let's get into it so good
she seems that when you confront them
good so so I'm not shake Iman your life
for a couple reasons I was a fan of
yours since I was quite young since I
was like 13
however as I started to learn the Deen I
came across some stuff you said which
was completely contradicting Islam okay
so we have a young person who's been
watching from day one 13 years old and
you see a lot of common trait with these
and a lot of youngsters who may watch
certain people whoever it may be they
start learning the religion yeah
learning the religion yeah by certain
codes in
videos you know cause members
individuals and then all themselves and
they start thinking oh I'm on the Huck
this is called the saved sect syndrome
the same-sex syndrome is a group of
people who think that they are on that
them and their cronies the you know the
hope means whoever they are they are the
one on the hop now I think what she's
we're going to find out let's carry on
said whoever I was I was new to the D
unites and my family was not a
practicing Muslim but at hamdulillah
over the years I came across people and
I started listening to we didn't put on
myself and started learning a key to
myself and handle in there and then I
came across a lot of stuff that you said
which was completely against the Quran
and Sunna okay listen this right before
she was in that practice and she didn't
or matters of al Qaeda
she started practicing reading the Quran
herself met individuals individuals and
now she has Naruto all of a sudden she
has been enlightened yeah just like this
the light on top of the camera
enlightening me
she's been enlightened and she's on the
hook now everybody is on the bat she's
on the hook now and now she's found out
that multi-link is a deviant subhanAllah
let's find out what other accusations
towards moved image we have to be just
speak the truth even if it's against
yourself or you can whoever it may be
well why he there is I can really
there's a lot of evidence a lot of
evidence not one two three and not and
you're here coming on Instagram live
with women who aren't even covering
their face like subhanAllah don't you
fear Allah don't you just a lot like it
ducky llama flamingo do you not fear
Allah subhana Allah
how dare you now this is one of the
phases when you go into the same set
syndrome and you think you were one of
the same set you start what you
you like didn't Amy on me a lot last
unit he says some people are like flies
you know what fly yeah actually doesn't
be sorry about that but the fly makes a
similar noise yeah like a fly they never
see any good in anybody and just like a
fly that lands on the wounds and on pure
on pure that's what they do
they never see the good in anyone they
always go they look for this custom
thing specific that's not bad let's go
to the bat that's what they do and this
is you can see from his attitude judging
why because mostly meant mostly meant
what does he do he is speaking to a
sister given down in general maybe she
might even be a non-muslim maybe there's
some one sister who doesn't wear the
hijab what do you want to do you don't
want the sister who doesn't wear a job -
hey the Dawa you know what kind of kind
of childish behavior is this but you
don't even want sister and then look at
the arrogance yeah look at the arrogance
you know you're you don't feel about
talking Yannick sometimes I walk down
with fruit sometimes a group of sisters
who may not wear the hijab or do comedy
I'll see your videos I don't think it
could not stop get away from me it could
not feel a lot and I start whipping them
I say when he comes around my sister
yeah how you guys doing good honey I'm
good and I came here to help you guys
win inshallah me on the best you any
advice any something okay so I'm on even
does it know if your witness a v6 engine
now you have fallen into sin how could
you how could you converse with the
sister in a decent way how would the
below and these are the same people but
I'm gonna turn trip this career people
look up to you and you're setting up a
bad example okay my sister just that one
point if I can just put forward
something you know my sister thank Allah
that he has allowed you to grow in a
beautiful way and we're all I'm quite
strict on myself but I tell you what we
have to reach out to people who are not
on our level and you know people who are
not on your level not everyone thinks
the same and not everyone is the same
the whole world is different
it was always different it's amazing to
be able to reach out to others to bring
them closer and closer to let's put
aside that didn't work that didn't work
so what do you talk about fly is looking
for work already and I'm trying to speak
to response and another note let's have
another comment there thank you for
reaching out non-muslims like me I'm
inspired mostly men is the only person
and I ask Allah subhanAllah he's
watching this to purify his intentions
yeah it's not good to pray somebody to
their face however I'm just saying it
most immense only person I've seen
non-muslims that know him that like is
Adam his character the Prophet peace be
upon him said I came from
but the perfect together how many of you
guys have memorize the Quran the hadith
any of the most disgusting attitude the
most violent attitude the most arrogant
behavior just like this system multi
mink is someone that we can say but
would it be may have probably had his
fault
we probably since it of course he sins
the point is this carrying Islam
do you carry some this video is gonna be
proof who is actually embedded with
Islam that is showing it let's see
sometimes they exactly
and this paresis I said she wasn't
practicing before well guess what sister
and if you remember you you said you was
a fan of Mothe Dominque at one point you
may have been one of those sisters that
could have come to his life he wasn't
wearing the hijab at that very moment of
time and something he said inspires you
and helped you to wear the hijab maybe
and there is a comment section of
another comment that comes up where
somebody says you helped me wear the
hijab so that could have been you so
right now where you're at are you
looking down at who you was before so
when you speaking oh you feel Allah you
are not representing the Quran and the
Sunnah cuz I'm the same said and you are
looking speaking the sisters are not
covering their face it is it cover their
job I would say about covering their
face there's a difference between then a
cop yeah shall banning me understand
about the opinion that it's not a fault
yeah and the rest should have been a
famous Oliver Falls and hold opinion it
is yeah so you talking about covering
the face to cut your arrogance look at
your arrogance how dare you speak this
is self righteousness and this can be a
form of arrogance behavior don't forget
sista
if you're watching this where you came
from where he was and a lot of
practicing people do this they practice
they're up here and they forget where
they can never the one who forgets that
pass would never know their future
actually from the evidence that everyone
has you're putting everyone back to
sleep IRA's saying dr. Anne is a history
book dr. Anne is no his second
accusation
oh then we say the first one didn't work
second accusation that the that Mufti
men apparently said the Quran is a
history book okay the movie man himself
clarify three books
we're supposed to look at you I think
you have enough time to talk you're
shutting me your China change the topic
so I don't do those tactics trying to
change the topic
[Music]
someone said that I said these things
that I didn't say they took and they
want to make it sound like I said it has
three things in it it has it has news it
has news of what happened before us you
cannot deny the stories of the story of
the story so that is an ID the poor on
so you cannot say that he doesn't have
it but that's not all that the poor has
it open has a judgment between us I pay
any money
Oh fumble ah ha ha
that's my slaw you have to you can't
just pull out a gun and start shooting
everywhere you can't be sitting at home
and just like run your mouth 24/7 you
you have to actually we have to see
action what about the three thousand
what about the three thousand Muslims
who died last you because of trump and
Russia and Syrian army okay
no three thousand millions let's get
more George Bush went to Iraq include
over a million people so the Tony Blair
this is an emotional statement do you
think we are not her when we see the
believers dying do you think what the
work do we do now extension we do it for
the fun and we just do it for the sake
of it
Jani you're the one that's the soldier
the only you are the hero that we don't
care you care you don't want that case
in the treaty of hudaibiya when the
treaty was done and the agreement was
made that believing men are going to be
returned men and women returned back to
the motional Keane returned back and
some of them were returned at that very
moment of time and if you look at it
people like you would be looking at that
and the Prophet is one line I have no
doubt that people like you is there you
will do takfeer of the Prophet you see
how are you
in a treaty with the mushrikeen they
worship other than Allah and you're
handing over believing men to them to be
tortured how are you making such an
agreement because young zealous people
like you do not have hikmah don't have
wisdom that's why the Prophet peace be
upon him he knew and Harada and when he
heard it he said he knows he's the
prophet of Allah
hey come on I was Fontana if I'm
mistaken every good sort of fat yep and
you think I said what what country was
happening there nothing but there is
wisdom a logic ma so she's having a go
at him oh you sitting at home in this
stuff yes these are the very girls who
run to Isis run to Isis and now they're
these Isis are finished and now they're
in these camps wanted to come back home
why because you've got gas height listen
to a bit of food she had dinner she's on
hiding in your bedroom with God knows no
stake thinking this Kalashnikov - yes
I'm gonna go you are dreaming fight the
because you had fight what inside you
because you've got a lot of work to do
sister you've got no work do internally
before you try to fight externally they
killed 3,000 people pay these are the
things you don't see in the news because
of deceptive chefs like yourself no look
how disgusting a new cheese and we're in
the moment I'm trying to speak for all
these idiots who actually follow you
like ok no this is key
Amina go she was talking about you know
talking to these girls these sisters
don't worry
you know the net carb with this arrogant
attitude now if a sister is not wearing
the face veil yeah she does believe it
to be fart if she's not sinning if you
from well she's not saying she's wearing
hair that covered and
she's not honey no she's not coming
innocent you have just backbitten
back bite it back bite it may be
slandered a group of Muslims maybe
thousands maybe millions you have a back
bite it you have wrong
not the person that sister doesn't wear
the veil on her face she's not sinning
yeah she's not sinning okay you have
just bad bit in them major sent back
bitten slumber medicine that bitten you
slander my email which you go it's
declared himself up and now you're back
biting and your system olymic is you
wearing a club and you must be no
respect for other human beings and
you're an idiot so the first thing you
need to correct about yourself is when
you're talking to those who disagree
with then to respect them they were
created by Allah created by my beloved
sister some of what you said so what I'm
trying to say is there is literally no
one listens to me I'm telling you let me
tell you that if this was really like
five years ago this would have been my
dream coming on liber8 you however I
watch it like yeah you would have been
coming online with mostly men was
probably not wearing a hijab because he
wasn't practicing then let's say
argument's sake but now you're the same
person who's in the court and in this
room now and when the hug and now you'll
be looking back yourself and repeating
yourself every single lecture I watched
it and at first I was really confused
and I was like subhanAllah I was okay I
watched most of it that's true that may
not be true but I'm mark I watch
I've watched about 90% of your lectures
I would literally keep up with
everything you posted all the time and
then eventually when I started reading
the out half of this stuff you said
conjugate it at contradicted
I'm talking about let me tell you this
Oh so you might want to resolve it in a
way what about the reason that could add
don't alas this wait a second guys
she's gonna drop that Quran verse any
second now
here we go sister please you're on the
hop I told there's no fitness Allah not
a talk we'll fight them until there is
no fitness surah Anfal verse 39 let's go
to the tafseer and see what have the
ulema the big scholars have said about
this abu hanifa and his followers have
said it refers to the fitna of Arabian
Peninsula paganism armed struggle was
continued against them until they were
annihilated so these were pagan Arabs
who were persecuting the Muslims day-in
day-out torturing them so some say that
verses specifically talking about that a
doubt listen carefully a doubt commonly
raised at this point needs to be
clarified by saying until religion is at
last what is meant is the remover of
those impediments and obstacles that
come in the way of our - servants
obstacles that take them take the form
of rules by those who do not implement
the divine law when these obstacles are
removed that people would have achieved
the full freedom base deserve as human
beings thereafter they might choose
freely acting under no constraint
their faiths and beliefs but the rule
remains allows which means power is
taken away from those who would utilize
it to influence the people in to choose
them other than what they would if they
were free in surah Hajj verse 39
the fight has been given to those who
would be thought so the fighting versus
if you look at it which would have no
idea it's talking about freeing the
mankind so when jihad was done at the
time of the Prophet peace be upon him
and after when they work on comparison
wrong they were going there to fight the
rulers the fighting men the general
people why
some scholars it was because of Dawa
because they wanted to be the people
were the rulers at the top were
oppressing the people to believe their
religion so they were fighting them so
the people can be free because we know
there is no compulsion in religion in
surah Baqarah verse 2 5 6 7 nothing that
says that there is no compulsion in
religion so that they can pick their
religion freely they don't want to they
pay the jizya the fighting men and they
live yes so that is what is talking
about what are you talking about fight
them it is that what are you talking
about you that's enough you're in this
farmer like in a movie
you can't just be studying at home and
giving dower like this this is not the
way to go you do look at this and this
is the reason why how young people's
like this get brainwashed by Isis fly
over there get used become a sex slave
yeah just for intimacy get chopped left
right center yeah which is done
prohibits yeah and then now she's young
yes you don't sit down you go
brainwashed
absolutely brainwashed when they was
second didn't sit back out that's
absolutely wrong if you look at first
and them most office more I wouldn't say
anything all this was was because they
were the the persecutors the pagan
errors the battle of hunayn
the Battle of Tabuk the battle of badr
the Battle of cohort the battle of han
da-eun aim it yeah you name it all of
them they were the ones who are
attacking undermine the giving dower in
a positive way people are coming to the
meal because of efforts of people who
speak to them with respect
it was never ever spread by the gun or
the sword and perhaps that's what you
think and you know what go and lend the
context of the verses that you're citing
because you've never learned context you
are just simply listening to people who
are brainwashing you to believe that the
basis of war means you must just take
them and apply them anywhere on earth so
anyway I've told you my piece
it's a dose inshallah that you endure
today I must that Sister Sister Jose
know about you said right lady you have
zero knowledge literally literally
nothing but an emotional tension you're
literally the only reason people are
showing you so much love is because they
don't know anything about the Quran and
Sunnah not a takbir all of these people
are following you yeah Mufti because
they don't know Quran and this one but
she does you know I cringe when I hear
that with some youngsters start practice
religion but we could go there on the
roads
it's just that we're on the hop put an
understood okay okay you're missing
should so upon Allah mixing truth with
falsehood Allah 20 years backbiting read
disrespectful disgusting doesn't know
any versus foreign accusations and she
can't even bring receipts do it you're
literally mixing treat with falsehood
you know you can't win now you're just
trying to say that you know in an in an
arrogant way to show her that you do
know what you're talking about
you can't even win now know what you're
gonna be called now who else knows more
than you love with but she dropped that
bar in least no I disappeared but yeah
he chose to be arrogant
comparing me with yours enemies breaking
about your knowledge you're out here
tell me how much knowledge you know your
I understand you know a lot because what
doin later they who makes the truth with
falsehood and you can't be doing that in
a snap Aslam is not a blood may Allah
bless you for giving me such an
opportunity also sister to show your
arrogance prophets and sisters I'm sorry
I was a little bit harsh but it was well
deserved and I really really enjoyed
this video I think it's about the whole
time I'm gonna go and have some food I
feel a bit better till next time
assalamualaikum what material better
care to and if you think you are on the
hop and the Quran and the Sunnah yeah
take it break relax yourself yeah go and
study your religion stick to studying
the basics of your religion and just
relax yourself please see you next time
assalamu alaikum warahmatullahi wa
better care to me and the makers amongst
those who have good other good character
that people see Islam in us rather than
here Islam from us good bye